are you sure we can't find this DeVoe
guy I mean we were warned wait it heads
up that someday someone named DeVoe
would be one of my greatest foes the
other thing to think about is do you
know how many people there are in this
state alone with the name DeVoe no
thousands and we still don't have an age
unless one of your greatest foes is the
three-month-old William DeVoe who lives
four blocks from here I don't think one
of my greatest enemies is a baby baby
you're right
we're gonna need more diapers diapers
Joe I'm pregnant well in return Wesley
is moved countermove what's your point
simply that mysterious stranger comes it
down seeks out the flash causes us to
open the Speed Force which causes the
creation of a dozen new metas all right
hold on
you think the guy behind the samurai
robot Sam right you think he wanted us
to create a busload of Metis Annie it's
all connected
I don't think one of my greatest enemies
is a baby you won't kill her baby
I can't have you running away not until
you've completed the task for which you
were before
killer baby my greatest enemy could
happen it's all connected so this is
gonna be my follow-up to the Joe baby
new reverse-flash theory that the
thinker is behind this new baby in wants
it for something specific but if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get everything we have so
much justice league stuff dropping next
week in the TV shows there's giveaway
stuff at the end of the video too so in
the last couple of episodes based on
things that the thinker has said
includes that the show has dropped a lot
of people are wondering what the
connection is between the baby in the
thinker there were some people that even
thought that the thinker might be Joe
and Cecile's baby in some weird way but
when you look at the actor here like his
face actually looks white in complexion
and this is the actor beneath all that
makeup so he's very clearly Caucasian
Joe and Cecile are both african-american
any baby that they would have would be
African American so that should be the
end of the theory that that baby is the
thinker but now people are wondering if
it might be the 12th metahuman because
even though the show is hiding it really
well she looks very pregnant I don't
know if the actress in real life is
pregnant and they just found this
interesting wait to work it into the TV
show but I do think there are a couple
reasons why they're doing the Joe baby
and I think they're all just trying to
weave it together so that it makes sense
by the end of the season with these
twelve metahumans so when Barry says at
the beginning of the season we're going
to need more diapers that meant we
already needed diapers and we just
learned about the Joe baby a little
while ago so the more diapers I think
means that they're still doing Barry and
iris children and that'll eventually
wind up being a season five thing just
because cecile having a baby is already
a big enough thing it'd be crazy if they
tried to do three different babies in
the back half of the season
that's like couple babies too many but
for all of you that were screaming for
Daniel West after Joe first learned that
he was pregnant that quote at the
beginning backs that up a little bit
because the idea that Daniel West would
grow up to become a reverse-flash which
is one of Barry's greatest enemies just
stacks up because there are only a
couple of West's that they could
actually name that baby and still be
comic-book accurate like assuming they
don't go completely off the rails and
call him Dave or jack or
something like that they'll pick one of
the classic West names from the comics
in Daniel West just hits all of those
bases he's one of Barry's greatest
enemies even though he was more of a new
52 villain but he was also iris West
brother so there's just like a couple
really important markers for who that
character could be and what this baby
could turn into like there was this
whole thing in the episode about Joe
being terrified of being a new parent
all we have to do is love the baby and
nothing will go wrong
so that automatically means that
something has to go wrong you have set
up payoff then reversal like they're
setting up the Barry iris wedding
they'll pay that off during the
crossover episode but the big reversal
is that they'll have the big attack from
Earth X you have all the Nazi characters
come for them so you set up the idea
that Joe West is going to have a new
child you pay that off in the back half
of the season once the baby comes to
term then there's a big reversal and
something crazy happens with the baby
then the icing on the cake is that very
specific thinker language not until
you've completed the task for which you
were born as in babies that are born so
there's just so many things pointing
towards this baby taking a dramatic left
turn in the back half of the season but
again that's all sort of adjacent to the
Barry iris storyline this year because
they're teasing the wedding the reason
why I think they're doing the wedding
this early in the show's run like
usually they would save that for the
final season like yeah you know they get
married and they have this wonderful
life together having all these
adventures is is because they want to
get to the idea of Bart Allen in the
speedsters from the future really Bart
Allen is the important one but you have
to do their children first and before
you can do that they have to get married
so which is one thing right after the
other so they get married they can
eventually do a season of Bart Allen
they could push it as late as they want
in the show's run the producers of tease
that they could go eight or nine seasons
there's a billion different flash
stories they could tell so there's
plenty of material to get them there but
when you're looking at big benchmarks in
the life of the flash like stories that
you would want to tell if given the
opportunity one there's Barry on
becoming the flash - there's Wally West
there's Jay Garrick in the classic
speedsters then you have Bart Allen he's
like the next step in that flash family
but in order to do him you have to
logically
introduced the idea the characters get
married have children they're speedsters
and then they passed that on down the
line it's the same thing with big series
like Game of Thrones like they want to
tell you who Jon Snow is so they give
you clues and early seasons and then
tease the idea of who his parents were
then you find out what his heritage is
and it allows them to do the really big
stories in the final season that you
want to see but they couldn't have done
something like Bart Allen in season one
without introducing the idea that Barry
wants to be with Iris they eventually
get married and have children in one of
those children ends up having Bart Allen
because he's Barry's grandson in the
cool thing about Bart Allen talking
about new reverse-flash is that you can
also circle back around to eobard thawne
because Bart Allen is 50% Thawne and it
is a big pain in the reverse flashes but
like he really hates Barry but he hates
Bart too because he shares DNA with him
so like they haven't done a whole lot of
classic reverse-flash this season
obviously there's the crossover episode
but once you get to the Bart Allen
season to the flash it also opens the
door for some really cool
eobard thawne interactions with
characters that are not barry but
there's still a thousand different
reverse-flash stories that they could
tell they still haven't done his origin
story so remember they go 8 or 9 seasons
just like they try to like separate each
season by a big idea and this is the
season where Barry and iris get married
and he doesn't face a speedster but I
think the real idea is is what are they
gonna do with Joe and Cecile's baby
after they solve whatever problem the
thinker sets to Barry at the end of the
season because if the baby winds up
almost becoming evil usually you defeat
evil things the show isn't gonna kill
the baby they'll have to find some way
to redeem it or there'll be some crazy
sci-fi twist it'll be interesting to see
if there is a baby on the TV show next
season whether it be iris and berries or
it be Joe and Cecile's so just don't be
surprised if something happens to Cecile
or she leaves town with the baby but I
don't know if they would do that because
it'd be a huge bummer remember Wally
West
grew up without a father so I don't know
that they would allow that to happen
again on the flash I think fans would be
really upset about that and Joe himself
would probably go crazy but let me know
in the comments what do you think the
deal is with
baby why do you think the thinker
created circumstances that would lead to
the birth of that baby because like that
long drawn-out sentence from Harrison
wells where he's like move counter move
Wally West leaves town metahumans appear
it just sounds like Joe and Cecile's
baby is one of the thinkers chess moves
and it's just playing a really long game
that won't pay off till the end of the
season but for those of you asking there
was a bit of a scandal that happened in
the last couple of days behind the
scenes that in no way is going to affect
the production of the flash TV show so
don't worry about that and I'm not gonna
speak about it too much until more
details come out and we learned what's
gonna happen but there is a new round of
the flash ring giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video congratulations to
the winner from my Justice League video
Luis Garcia please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details you can click here
to watch that non spoilery Justice
League reaction video and you can click
here for the brand new agents of shield
season 5 trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight